can you pull up the video of trump with
Midas Touch and uh they share this and
there's a whole Community right now
people that are saying well you would
never show this on the podcast there's
no way you're going to talk about this
on the podcast no we kind of like to see
both sides of the argument this argument
is this whole situation with Silicon
Valley Bank is Trump's fault if he can
play this clip the legislation I'm
signing today rolls back the crippling
Dodd-Frank regulations that are crushing
Community Banks
and Credit Unions Nationwide they were
in such trouble
one size fits all
those rules just don't work and
Community Banks and Credit Unions should
be
regulated the same way and you have to
really look at this they should be
regulated the same way
with Proviso for safety as in the past
when they were vibrant and strong but
they shouldn't be regulated
the same way as the large complex
financial institutions and that's what
happened and they were being put out of
business one by one
and they weren't Lending
since its passage in 2010 Dodd-Frank has
dealt a huge blow
to community banking
as a candidate I pledge that we would
rescue these Community Banks from
Dodd-Frank
the disaster of Dodd-Frank
and now we are keeping that commitment
and all of the people with me are
keeping
that commitment we passed and signed a
record number of bills terminated at
this point so so when you see this your
understanding if you if either one of
you guys Barry or Tom what was the cause
of Dodd-Frank we know what happened
under Obama Barack Obama what was the
cause of Dodd-Frank and at the same time
What credibility do you give to what
Midas Touch and some of these guys are
talking about saying if Trump wouldn't
have deregulated some of these
regulations in Dodd-Frank this would
have never happened with Silicon Valley
Bank it wasn't because the loans were
not performing it wasn't because of bad
investment it was a duration mismatch it
happened because the FED went about a
course to raise rates in an
unsustainable manner without thinking
about unintended consequences if these
would have been
Investments that were turning up bad
that's one thing and then you could say
okay the fact that what was done here
and I believe that it isn't spoken about
in this clip but I believe what they're
discussing here is when he rolled back
the reserve requirement of how much
you'd have to keep for a small Bank
where it was it was removed that's that
the reserve requirement said that those
Banks could invest that money and wind
up making more profitability which had
which gave them options It Made for More
competition so I'm not saying right or
wrong I'm just trying to outline it
because I don't think that that really
displays what what the what the ruling
was that he removed so if if these were
bad loans that went bad well then you
could go back to this clip and said you
know what if you would have had more
stranger rules and they made less
Investments maybe they would have been
smarter Investments okay but the
Investments were good
it just was a duration mismatch that
wasn't managed Tom what would you say
about that I I did the two things first
of all the game when you have a weak
leader in the White House is the blame
predecessor so trains are getting
derailed oh Trump changed a ruling on
one type of cargo yet he's responsible
for all change derailing now this
happens here oh this would have happened
wait a minute why haven't we had five or
ten Banks if Trump created a situation
where the banks could run willy-nilly
why do we only have one bad actor why
and that bad actor Dodd-Frank reserve
requirement forced to take Capital if
you're insolvent no exotic instruments
transparency and Reporting none of that
is present here in what happened with
Silicon Valley Bank these boneheads took
20 billion dollars put it into bonds
risk officer leaves nobody's paying
attention to the portfolio and then they
end upside down in member seven less
than seven months
Jay Powell moves the rates and they're
upside down so do they sell it in a
panic right that no they hung on to it
see and guess what he raised them again
and then it got worse so I don't see
anything under Dodd-Frank and I'd love
to see a tear down that says okay what
specific red light did svb run that was
not present in Dodd-Frank light after
Trump's move by the way I agree with you
the question yeah but but also Tom let's
remember within Dodd-Frank it gave svb
the ability to use hold to maturity and
not take the haircut right there they
were able to declare that it was the
total value that's what the problem was
in a lesson nobody learned
if anybody has watched The Big Short you
know that Mark to Market hiding in the
background is ultimately what kills big
stacks and this is this was what exactly
what Dodd-Frank allowed SBB to do so
dot-frank allowed for this yes it did
not the other way around exactly right
because Dot Frank allowed for the
provision that you now that 15 billion
lost you don't have to take it as a loss
you could say we're going to hold it to
maturity even though the market value
like Tom was saying they didn't have to
mark that to Market it doesn't come off
your tier one Capital as long as it's in
one of the assets that's deemed no risk
like an agency a balance sheet footnote
by and by the way by law that's all they
had to do Rob Rob just found this if we
can take a look at this in 2018 the
house passed a rollback of regulations
in Dodd-Frank by a vote of 258 to 150
not even close and in the Senate 17
Democrats joined Republicans so this is
both Democrats and Republicans joining
together to get the bill to Trump's desk
and sign into law which raised the bill
raise the threshold for regulation
standards from 50 billion to 250 billion
which left less than 10 banks in the U.S
subject to stricter uh Federal oversight
and allowed Banks under 250 billion in
assets to escape increase scrutiny go
ahead well I just since we're kind of
dipping our our toes into the political
side of things you want to address what
Biden said today I kind of summarized
this whole speech I want to wrap this up
before we go and but here's the thing
with with this part for people to be
thinking about uh if if it it's very
easy for both sides to do this this
isn't a Republican or a Democrat thing
both sides do it where they're like yeah
but this was his fault yeah but it was
that fault and probably everybody in
this room guilty of doing this before
here's a challenge though for how long
did Biden's Administration have control
of the house senate and to be able to do
how long well if they had it for two
years how come they didn't do anything
with this you had two years it's plenty
of time so if if you're saying well you
know it's his fault well then it kind of
becomes your fault because you could
have actually done something about it
for two years and you never thought
about this so if that's the case whose
fault is it really or can we just set
this thing aside and say let's deal with
this direct to make sure this doesn't
happen again to another bank today but
but my biggest concern of this before we
go to the Biden
here's my concern
so my concern uh uh I'm kind of debating
in my head and I'm going back and forth
okay and I'm trying to not stick to one
side of the argument on one end I
understand the frustration of people
saying hey capitalism for the you know
poor and socialism for the rich I get it
and on the other side I'm like okay
we do need more Regional Banks
we need more Banks period okay
this crisis to be honest with you just
made chase a lot stronger right if you
think about this this crisis how many
people in America had this conversation
three nights ago husband and wife that
are in bed they're having this
conversation together hey babe yeah babe
uh babe the bank were with is it one the
bigger Banks or is the regional uh let
me find out babe it's a regional are we
what kind of we were a community oh but
did you did you see what's going on babe
look let's just be safe and go to one of
the bigger guys who do you think should
go to I don't know Larry my cousin said
go to Bank of America all right Larry go
to Bank of America hey Johnny is at
Chase let's go to Chase how many people
you think in the last week that's the
data I would want to know how many
people left smaller Banks to go to the
bigger Banks that's the risk now some
people may say well that's the right
move to make that is the exact way it
needs to be we need to go there let me
ask you this other question do you think
Tesla
forced other car makers to innovate
faster
do you think Tesla was good for the
economy the answer is what of course it
was absolutely it made everybody say we
better get our together before this
guy
it's our lunch right do we think we we
did a Rob what did we do two weeks ago
when we're talking about the weapon
manufacturers where we showed how they
went from 51 uh uh companies down to
five do you know which one I'm talking
about the javelin it's a lateral chart
this way where it goes you end up with
only Boeing and Lockheed and do you
remember that it was 51 if you can look
it up see if he can find it it was 51
companies that we had 45 years ago where
the market could compete to see who to
get their weapons from who to get there
you know anything they wanted and it
went from 51 to 40 to 30 to 20 to now
five well the fewer we have the less
competition there is so there's more
bullion the fewer Banks we have Believe
It or Not socialists want that they want
it to be nationalized banking they want
that that's more of a control of course
that's more of a controlled by the US
government single-payer healthcare is by
far the worst think it is by far the
worst thing for you and I because they
get to bully us so again as much as this
is if I'm on the Democratic side and I
kind of want to get my the top five
banks to get stronger guess what I'm
doing right now this is exactly what I'm
doing right now get your money out of
regionals this is exactly can you zoom
in please thanks for finding it Rob if
you can zoom in a little bit look at
this this is showing we used to have 50
plus companies in 1980 to buy uh uh uh
you know Aerospace any kind of weapons
anything we wanted down from 1980 25
Lockheed Boeing Raytheon Northrop and
General Dynamics if we go the way we're
going right now and the big Banks use
this crisis we all know the Same by Rahm
Emanuel never let a crisis go to waste
if they use this crisis this is a great
season for the bigger Banks the bigger
bullies to eliminate a lot of the
community and a lot of the regional
competition yeah that's what I'm
concerned about yeah
seen in retail though I mean it used to
be mom and pop shops all over the
country and now it's Amazon Walmart and
Target if you're locking Sam's and Sam
so is consolidation that bad of a thing
in general or is it depending on the
second an area that you need Innovation
it is you know but so so innovation
ideas you your banks are important
they're they're part of the fabric of
life you go to your local bank you have
relationship with them you know it's
it's important yeah it's it's a it's uh
uh we we as much as uh you know from the
safety standpoint the average person
could say that's exactly why I'm going
to take my bank you know my money Wing
go to a uh bigger one it is not going to
long-term workout for uh everyone there
you do not want that if you look at the
numbers I looked it up earlier a
Community Bank in America we have 2 250
Community Banks in America this is
ranges 10 billion to 100 billion that's
what they're cons the Community Banks
are that size uh large banks in America
we have uh uh 38 of them this is banks
that are worth a hundred billion or more
I think Chase if you can pull it up you
had it earlier Rob it's a 3.2 trillion
dollar Bank 3.2 trillion hours and there
you go chase is 3.2 trillion dollars in
assets then it's B of A City look it
even Wells is uh at the top they don't
put it as safety all the way at the top
U.S go all the way to the bottom until
it gets to 100 billion if you can do
that to see how many we got boom boom
Silicon Valley keep going yeah there's
38 of them that we have and in regionals
we only got 27 of them
um Rob scroll back up a little bit let
me just say the top ten
got it golden side we need we need more
competition we definitely need more
competition the last thing we need is
consolidation we do not need
consolidation if you want to go into uh
uh President Biden gave a speech earlier
today I think it was four minutes and 10
seconds give or take he talked about how
deposits will be there okay uh he talked
about the problems with bank he brought
up Dodd-Frank on what they did and how
he blamed Trump and he talked about
unemployment under four percent for
straight months and he talked 14
straight months and he talked about
protecting depositors so it's a very
much quick four minutes ten seconds wait
he also took credit for 12 million jobs
created which is put back the ones that
went shut down that came back I mean
yeah that's a very ridiculous statement
to make I'm sorry I just took notes down
specifically regarding the bank run and
Silicon Valley Bank he said the FDIC
took control of all assets for the banks
and by the way it wasn't just Silicon
Valley Bank what's what's the Regional
Bank that that also just went under
silvergate so no no not silvergate
signature signature signature
yeah he's right so it was a week and a
half ago and they were a crypto bank got
it so here's some of the highlights of
what Biden to say all customers are
going to be protected and will have
access to their money there's going to
be no losses to taxpayers that's you
know something you wanted to point out
and we talked about this earlier where
these fees are coming from all fees we
paid by the what the banks pay into this
FDIC fund
um that all management from these banks
will be fired and the investors into
these banks will not be protected and
obviously his overall goal here is to
eliminate any
stress and people freaking out for these
Bank runs we were discussing earlier so
it was interesting to me that he used it
to point blame but the blame is is
misappropriated here let's understand
what happened
the reason why the FED okay so we have a
mismatch in duration that happened
because the Fed was extremely aggressive
why was the FED extremely aggressive
because they were overly
accommodative and culpable as well was
government which was overly stimulative
in combination they created this
inflation so you have the arsonist is
now become the firefighter so this is
where the problem is now by the way what
the FED did today I applaud them they
had to save the depositors I agree with
that but their moves to maniacally
increase rates that's like if somebody
heaven forbid if somebody's ill and you
say okay I'm going to give you some
medicine five minutes later you're not
better I'm gonna give you another dose
I'm gonna give you another dose I'm
gonna this is what they're doing because
it takes a while for this to happen I've
got some stuff on inflation that they're
trying to fight if you ever want to take
a look at it up there that shows
inflation's going to come down if they
just understood how it worked and if
they just saw what causes it to come
down so if you like this clip and you
want to watch another one click right
here and if you want to watch the entire
podcast click right here
[Music]